up now with journalist martha gill emma
wed from the free speech union
co-founder of the muslim debate
initiative abdullah al andalusi let's
start with you if we can abdullah um
quite a strong rhetoric from douglas
murray um i'm always aware that
muslim extremists do not in any way
speak for the majority of muslims but to
be fair the iranian government over the
weekend said russia was to blame for
being attacked that is completely and
utterly despicable isn't it
well firstly um
i find it rather
uh strange that douglas murray who's had
a history of advocating for restrictions
on muslim speakers at universities you
can answer
have said that that he took it on
himself he was stabbed in broad daylight
but if i may um he he deigns to say he's
a champion for free speech so to speak
but yet he his organization argued for
restrictions on uh for platforms for
muslim speakers going to universities he
wanted to ban the burqa in public
buildings and you and a kind of social
ban on it in public
um so for him and
conditions for muslims in europe must be
made harder across the board let's bring
this back in douglas dug this way i find
it a little bit i would find a little
bit strange that he should um deign to
call himself um brazenly call himself
some or at least imply he's some kind of
champion for free speech a free
expression look i probably got to answer
that you'll have noticed and all of your
viewers will notice that this islamist
lunatic in your studio can't answer the
basic question let's try it again and
make it simple for you why don't you say
whether or not you are completely
condemning of any violence against
salman rushdie or anyone else who is
deemed to have said something heretical
why don't we start with the basics for
you
okay first i want to answer his question
because he asked me first which is about
the iranian regime well having not been
an iranian citizen nor participating in
any elections to elect the iranian
regime the reigning doesn't really
represent 1.8 billion muslims okay so if
you're here representing 1.8 billion
muslims it's very simple douglas has
just said it do you
do anyone do all right as your own self
having heard what he said do you accept
people saying be the iranian government
or muslim extremists and i made the
caveat and i repeat it muslim extremist
one of the biggest problems i have is
that people look at the whole thing and
they shouldn't do you agree with anybody
who comes up with the sentence he was to
blame for being knifed in broad daylight
15 times in his neck do you the only
person to blame for the knifing of
salman rushdie is the um the assailant
himself not the not the iranian regime
who put the fat well on him in the first
place well unless you can unless you can
demonstrate that they were specifically
colluding or they sent an agent they
said
he was in communication with the
arraignment
and that's and that's their opinion
right but i'm only here to talk about if
you're asking me who's to blame i say
the assailant much like douglas murray
said that the christ church killer the
one who massacred the muslims
what you'll find is that if somebody put
a millions of dollars on someone's head
yours for instance or mine and somebody
then attacked us you would think that
the person who'd put millions of dollars
on our head would bear some
responsibility you know because you're
such a dishonest weasel you're not even
willing to do that you're not even
willing to do the basic thing of
condemning the attack
sticks and stones
this is my program martha gill
journalist what's your opinion on this
situation
well it's it's completely horrific i i
completely agree um
with the other twos with douglas murray
um in that uh if putting a bounty on
someone's head in the first place is an
act of violence uh whether or not that's
followed up by people taking taking on
the challenge and clearly
somebody has and they are entirely to
blame for that let's move on to um
i wanted to ask you generally you've
been quite open about free speech when
does free speech cross a line martha
so every society has every functioning
society has to have some limits on free
speech if you agree with any
law on hate speech then you agree on
limits uh to free speech in society um
you know if you say actually
it's fine to say anything you quickly
run up against the paradox which is that
you say it's fine to somebody to go on
tv and call for the death of somebody
else for an expressing of you so their
freedom of speech is immediately
restricting
the freedom of speech of others so you
do need some limits on free speech in a
free society now of course we can argue
where you draw the line he's going to
say
emma would you say we've gone too far
in restricting free speech i think
absolutely we have i agree with douglas
that i think that short of incitement
those things that are illegal under the
law incitement being things like for
example putting a fatwa out on somebody
that would count as incitement in my
book because it's actively calling for
violence against someone um and in this
case for something that someone has
written does excitement compel people to
actually be violent
does it incite them it encourages them
if if if you are through if you are
through a group or a clan or whatever
you want to say and i'm treading
carefully for obvious reasons if you
feel that you're following uh a group
whatever it is and they're telling you
to do something and you go you're
sitting there saying that that bloke
wasn't i mean that's not my free will
though isn't isn't the whole basis of
the western system based on people's
freedom do you believe that man would
have gone and stabbed salman rushdie
unless he had been encouraged
incentivized galvanized whatever words
you want from people the iranian
government who say salman rushdie is to
blame i'm putting a fatwa on his head
that's wrong i'm simply saying that
unlike knee jerk dog whistle politics we
hear from douglas murray um
we why why don't we wait to the court
case to see what motivate the individual
i'm waiting for the evidence i'm waiting
like what does he say motivated if he
said it was motivated
fine i accepted do you not think he
might have been i guess yeah it might
have been right yes um i'd like to
finish my yeah
so we have in this country a teacher who
is still in hiding the back the teacher
from batley grammar school because he
showed a cartoon of the prophet muhammad
to his class he's still in hiding with
his young family that is in this country
now i think that what we have done as a
result of uh everything that happened
with salman rushdie in the intervening
33 years i think that we have
internalized this census this attitude
of censorship so that now if somebody
wanted to write a book like salman
rushdie's book that no publisher would
touch them because they would know what
the implications would be for that
person because we've internalized the
we've internalized sharia law on this
we've internalized in in many ways we've
internalized the censorship of radical
ideological groups
i don't think you can compare a
illiberal regime such the one in iran to
the one here
that's not what i was doing no no of
course but you can't really compare the
types of restriction on free speech we
have some restrictions laid down in law
they have some they have a huge number
of restrictions enforced by their
government and ruling groups the way
that free speech gets restricted here is
more by processes of consensus and
debate like the debate we're having here
on where line should be drawn it's often
done with individuals you can pretty
much say anything you like if you find
the right audience for it i would love
to sit here all night i literally am
being shouted out
we could continue this uh to all of you
abdullah thank you so much indeed uh
douglas murray from new york martha gill
and obviously emma webb everybody has an
opinion um somebody said to me today the
attacker of sam and roshi like millions
of others worldwide almost certainly had
absolutely no knowledge of the satanic
verses a book that came out 33 years ago
so one would have to wonder is he just
an evil person or is he motivated what
are your thoughts it's important at the
end of the day everybody will have their
own opinion